bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons ensemble
jouer malaise tv c'est pour toi
des fois il faut que j'apprenne à juste
continuer les essentiels à savoir
youtube qui se trouve sur god tenghory
voilà comme ça je suis à l'abri de tout
malaise tout se passe bien on est sur
game boy souvenez vous c'est le jeu
l'espèce apis wilson 3d un essai aussi
la vidéo avec la miniature plus
dégueulasse de youtube de ces deux
dernières années merci lucas hochart
c'est pour vous il ya eu des nouveaux
level comme on peut le voir ici présents
donc on va s'empresser de les faire on
commence avec comme bras car ceci est un
nouveau personnage la famille yang et
moi je prends la famille yang
pourquoi l épave à la [ __ ] la raciste
de merde au bayern on prend le russe
comme avec son gros choc violent dans le
coffre on n'est pas rivaux dit à mes
parents à non je peux du lac à jon par
les carottes c'est mon jab baseball non
on est type à on part sur l'évolution du
cassage de glace pour moi c'est toi qui
aime bien ce palace passe par la
cicciolina star bonhomme était un petit
pas au caoutchouc
on va pas demi-tour d'agréer eyes are
high timber dessus est ce que c'est
normal non olive ayolo backflip ya l'air
pâle est un [ __ ] beaucoup skis verbale
avec respect oui car le succès de la
nuit fera attention toujours pas de
famille en mai aps hectares quand est-ce
là pour la prendre
oulala c'est quoi c'est tout qui roule
c'est pas des bombes ce à tout hasard
dans ses pastèques ça va tout se passe
bien
ah c'est humiliant le faire décrit comme
chez pascale bravo je crie pour rien
c'est incroyable mais cette fois on est
six mois on va contourner tu vois passer
assez loin du canon allait plus tard
mais chez quelques sachets d'acheter ce
quad mais j'ai jamais vu un point aussi
peu maniable aller volos aller volos a
fait pas un boulot ce pardon qui a vu
que tu fais attention tu saignes de
l'intestin avec m'étais bas mais regarde
le quad tu laissais tu l'achète pas
l'être dos des frenchies
comme dirait ma prof d'anglais allez on
y va c'est gagner annonce maffini lolo
au [ __ ] mais en plein dedans quoi
attend comment faire je pense qu'il faut
arriver plein bal comme ça
en fait fait aller comme ça je pense là
il parla si quelqu'un y croit il lève la
main aux tiens tiens chica personne qui
a levé la main va dans ton cul il y
avait une patiente a gagné mon pote
maintenant une vidéo où je m'occupe la
cua a pu acheter un deuxième pot de
fleurs donc j'en ai 4 2 faire des
constructions de ouf lourds ou pas alors
le mail suivant toujours avec lire la
600 m objectif vous regardez c'est quoi
ça bah ce marathon de paris qu'on fait
là à savoir que ça fait des hausses et
vous voici super bon ce que vous faites
les gars c'est super ah oui par la chute
est moins bête je pense qu'en passant
par la dg en a plus de chances d'y
arriver
radio laissez moi après de ce caillou me
reposer en paix vous n'avez donc aucune
pitié donc ça c'est un le pen de
difficulté moyenne et les impatients du
hard c'est parfait toujours avec herbal
et et quads sont jetés ou préférer le
vélo voilà ce sera bien mieux que le
guay avec son quad pour il a un vélo
c'est bien plus maniable d'accord et ben
mabrouk rires j'ai compris va prendre
irait son quad l'aide de l'échec est
parfait pour y arriver tout est une
question de timing en accéléré du coup
on passe le truc
ok faut ralentir la lah pour accéder à
l'enclos mais magnifique magnifique
parfait parfait à l'hercules comme ça on
a esquivé la cie mais comment je passe
la cahc quad ou yolande bon bâle et cluj
peut encore conduire chez npd j'aime ça
c'est beau
[ __ ] c'est beau j'arriverai
j'arriverai vous me répète pas je veux
que vous passez pas mal échos
excellent alors j'ai jamais changé le
même si vite hardwood peut m'arriver
rater le prochain match et quad il à 200
mètres mon gars ah c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon j'ai retenu c'est incroyable
oh oui
passionnant ce jeu ah merde voilà
stéphane de trop mais non et je vous
jure que tu auras droit tout seul non je
vous promets perso j'ai vu des débuts
son bras il est né est un petit peu
affaissé là du côté droit donc il ya
moins de patates pour tenir le guidon
ballester vais je te régales aujourd'hui
ouais ça peut être les cousins ces
conneries et les bleus checkpoint m'en
bats les couilles de tournage futur
style et merci la petite chauve souris
tu peux t'en aller on t'aime
les troncs d'arbres et round armé qui
sera encore avoir parlé de robert son
épouse
[ __ ] les gars là ça devient un record
du nord mais vraiment quoi encore oui le
film un peu pour y filmer après la
personne moi je vous dis j'ai commencé à
me regarder ses rangs de la merde allez
on y va on y va on y va
il passe maintenant allez on peut y
aller oui [ __ ] me dit pas quoi finir
un niveau en difficulté à non non c'est
pas possible j'y crois pas bien il va
avoir une 1001 trucs
merci à tous et moi j'ose dire que cette
vidéo sur ghost and glory n'était pas là
mais ça vous appuyez j'adore / je trouve
très sympa la nouvelle par contre il
faut un niveau de ski le plus proche du
mikado que du squeeze quoi sur l'échelle
du skill ce qui serait drôle en vrai je
trouve ce serait de pouvoir faire des
courses comme ça en multi ce serait
fantastique tu démarres côte à côte avec
ses potes et tu t'en vois à se prendre
une seat explose de rire avant la fin de
tout ce qu'on annonce toute cette
prochaine phase avoir gardé par ses vous
bientôt tout le monde je suis pas de
panne